previously on raft it has been so long
my beard grew backwards and my nose
broke again guys I see a big dome ahead
at the place
yeah it's your forehead
hey a dome it's almost as big forehead
wait do you even know how to pile of
this boat you can't imagine the skill it
probably takes I spent so much time
doing everything that doesn't involve
sitting in a chair and turning the wheel
that I don't know how to do the easy
part I just watched Market drink all
this water and not refill pretty good
oh there's a gutter guys I might have
done it bad guys problem Lee Mark
problem have you found the fields of
electrical conduction oh electric juice
yeah okay there you go
guys you gotta see this
yeah it's cool
that's a creepy statue
oh hey Electric juice
yeah it's fun times in here wood tell
you what you you guys need help oh
clearly not clearly we're fine okay
sounds like why would we need help I
don't know just asking
did you want to go to surface access
wait did you find tape wait come here uh
hold on
hell yeah you have tape right
out I don't think uh I already got tape
to get through to there so I don't think
you need to worry about that
oh hey Mom hey what's up
I didn't see you there ah good to see
you did you just sniff me
no all right
Mark hey come on over here let me show
you my city
uh why is it your city I found it first
captain of this Voyage
or anything we find during the voyage is
mine robot
he's probably friendly oh he's soon to
be
oh he's probably friendly yeah he knows
who the real boss is uh the owner of
this place see oh wow
a key card
you're welcome all right all right
first order of business on my Island I'm
instituting a taxation system I think
it's only fair for raising money for the
various Services I will provide as the
leader uh moderate I hear you
to start okay
I hear you but note I'll never know but
note now we've got the votes working
we'll be gathering up a few more
survivors before we head off the rafters
either hit up in the apartments or left
to see
most of them seemed sick no wonder they
were so desperate
we need to hurry those large rats that
came with the right guys I'm in an
elevator aggressive this seems pretty
bougie I think we live in a world where
it's covered in water and we live on a
raft that we make with Dave and stuff
well I mean I'm also in an elevator so
first off
it's pretty common I think uh it's not
that special but
um I think we deserve this level of
booze
and uh it's only fair it's only fair I
would never
phrased it like that that we deserve it
but we do yeah why wouldn't we we worked
hard I have a feeling you boys are gonna
get exactly what you deserve okay guys I
got a token
we got a token uh I the captain yeah
it's called Brad found one tape
oh
oh I don't have my machete oh what's
that you need some kind of Machete oh do
you have a machete
maybe you got a manchetti well there's
various doors that are all taped up that
we might I might have a man's Getty for
you you guys get him
[Music]
You're Gonna Miss Getty
that's a terrible idea
I shouldn't be climbing on the outside
of the buildings but here I am I agree
with your assessment oh God this is a
problem on the inside of the buildings
okay
all right
yeah
what was the point of this I don't know
I'm basically back where I started now
sir
I don't think I did it right I fell oh
it's the bear stuck in the man's nose
penis all right our old friend all right
I guess the illusion of this being our
first time here is lost I mean what do
you mean I saw that painting back in the
old world
oh my God it's a super Badger rat oh a
rat Badger rat
it's not funny I seem to need a machete
Oh weird interesting potatoes had some
kind of friend that you hadn't uh
shunned that had a machete when did we
shot I was with you through thin and
thin I mean that is that is kind of the
time when you need friends so I guess
that's that's good right you need to you
need friends for thick you need well
when why don't you need thick friends I
don't think you need thick friends I
want thin and thin I want thick look I
just want the thin times those are the
times that I need help what what is a
thin time as opposed to a thick time can
I can we clear you know before I commit
to this too much
all right yeah actually let's clarify
this okay so a thin time would be when
resources are thin when your stretched
thin emotionally
um
very thin penis day you know like the
the time we all have those we all have
those
we we need friends most on those thin
thin days
you know when I'm when I'm thicked up
when I'm thick I don't need anyone
getting in my way
yes yeah so Daddy and out you're good
yeah I feel like uh you know having
friends through those times is just
redundant
anybody got a machete oh yeah our friend
Bob does all right cool oh that's very
kind of you to say like that my lover
Bob does Bob's with us through thin and
thin
I mean and thick I'm not a thin I'm not
a thin guy okay I'll take it yeah I
don't need it thicker hey I found the r
studio if a person who painted bear nose
why are you all of a sudden a lot better
who is that who are you
just jumped out of the roof of building
who are you
I I have the I have okay I hope that hid
oh man it was that mysterious stranger
are you near the intersection of
Sinclair Lane in Maine I don't know are
you look over here at me stop moving
you halt
that must not be me is that you mark
uh it could be anybody you see me over
here on the balcony I see a weird pig
man hopping just hopping over there like
a freak whoa calm down oh
moved his head okay well I'm just gonna
go this way then all right fine there's
a macheteable in there I don't see it oh
sorry you gotta ride the zip line down
then there's a macheteable oh I'm gonna
have to go out and get more water uh
move the boat around I open the door
I don't know how to drive it so probably
won't yes beyond your comprehension
don't know how to drive it yeah yeah is
there fall down imagine there is fall
damage right
uh yeah
Bowl
it is somewhere in there
it's around be to doubt is around man I
opened up an exit but I don't see a raft
yeah you gotta drive it
pretty sure it's gone that's a problem
oh look a machete opal door
sounds like that mysterious roof
stranger might have been right about it
there was one Tolkien in here
yeah was that worth it what are the
tokens for
uh to buy stuff from the vending
machines I think all right
useful stuff
bear nose penis painting hello oh I see
a bear nose penis painting I see that
the classic I bet the artists have
worked on that literally cries himself
to sleep because they're like it's very
meaningful and special to them and we
just call it bear nose penis painting I
shouldn't have made a bear nose penis
painting yeah
all right would you draw a bear nose
penis you get what you get in terms of
reaction okay hey I found another
machete door they're literally in every
one of these buildings yeah um what I
went in that's so weird
I found another one also literally just
now I found another one so if you could
I'm on the rooftop where I was yelling
at you before where where am you from
here where am I I'm in not me why is it
only him you care I'm in the building by
a machine I don't really care about any
of you where are you wait can you
describe to me where you are well I was
in the corner of Sinclair in Maine now
I'm uh there's bacon kissing cheese face
um
um I see founder Society sign
near a big tower a Black Tower are you
sure it's not just dark and it's
actually a normal looking Tower
well I'm looking through these fancy
rich people windows so I'm not sure also
there's a guy with nipples on his butt
uh in here
um oh there's bear nose penis face what
about a what about a penis what did you
say well this bear nose penis face no
before that
there's uh the nipple butt picture
uh I haven't heard about this like a guy
with his mouth open
approaching two cheeks with green
different size nipples
that's weird
um
let me show you no no actually actually
extremely no
mostly because of the way you said it
um I was actually would have been okay
but it was the way that you said that
particular sentence that just
no do you guys know that we can buy our
own print of bear nose penis
oh
God tradition put it on the business
card
ow
these rats it's like they're starving
where are the street sign names where
are the names of the oh hey robot friend
hey I see the founder Society sign and
I'm at the corner of Maine and partisan
Street have you seen the picture of a
piece of bacon kissing um like a younger
version of the Blowfish Lady from
SpongeBob wait who's in the street look
up at the window near the robot I'm up
here
I think it might be a trap don't do it
is that you oh yeah I see you yeah
there's a there's a machete thing in
this place
which how about whereabouts do I get up
in there damn it damn it I'll try to
take the elevator down real quick also
I'm about to die from high hey
no
this is even harder now ah I made it
what the trail
I made it
man why am I just finding crates of
hinges I feel like I should get a quest
item or something
oh there's a crate in here that had
leather a hinge and explosive powder
yeah
bro hinges
oh let's hinged up um there was another
building not far from here that had
another one of those there's a lot of
other buildings nearby this guy yeah
he's with me I have chosen sides now
haven't I he's breathing
ah
what that's all right did you just get
electrocuted in Gary's fun
damn it you made me fall hi oh
that's why I opened this stuff do you
know where the raft is we can go get the
raft real quick I need to open one of
these I I don't uh we should not do that
um have you guys been in the barber
uh couldn't open the door never mind
can't open the door to the barber I mean
you're right next to us hmm
but where are they
another exit door damn I would have been
able to get to the top of the barber but
I fell off right when you guys made me
laugh
oh no so are we too funny for you yeah
maybe pretty strong man yeah whatever
shut up come on leave I'm not hey wait
there's our boat our boat's right here
he found our boat
oh no
I'm back on the boat if you guys want a
quick access the boats like oh God the
shark has just been free ran on the boat
I actually am gonna have to derail Bob
right around this one of these tall
buildings had the zip wire and the
machete but I've got to get water I will
be dead soon Mark where are you bringing
the boat to which exit I'm not bringing
the boat it's already at an exit and
that's a depressed llama
oh he's so sad water it's crops if you
know what I mean what
I think along its grass if you know what
I mean no I don't
well I think I do but I really don't
wanna if it's different than what I
think it is
um I'm not gonna make it to the raft I
might die soon
see your bucket in its area if you know
what I mean
uh Wayne where where are you uh because
you might hear Bob at an exit you might
be running to the wrong exit well it's a
circle So eventually we'll get to the
right one yeah here's the problem I
can't Sprint anymore
uh lift your knees you gotta get your
knees up your knees and lungs yeah have
your knees forward okay forward so you
know the door that was already opened
you go right from that door that you
guys found before uh that's probably not
true no it is please tell me that's the
one so I'm not gonna make it to another
one it's not you're definitely not close
though
I think we've ran the opposite direction
yeah
yeah but at this point we've gone so far
around did you just die so I could carry
you uh well I mean I guess so you want
to die this robot right here no no not
in range of an enemy that I would then
have to kill without dying myself okay
really inconvenient oh okay you guys
okay don't worry Bob's got me that's
fine okay do you know where the exit is
ah obvious on the other side of the door
hello oh hey hey yeah we definitely ran
the opposite direction and just circled
the entire okay so all the exits are
open now so we'll never be able to find
the right one that's really cool
so yeah right didn't we yeah why did you
open it you could have looked out the
window and saw that it wasn't there now
in case we need to get out
we're it's we're at it we can get out of
here hmm interesting okay so what do we
need to do to actually solve the mystery
of this we need to climb the center
Tower thing
yeah I don't there's some kind of code
that we need that involves
what there's something crazy I had a
watermelon I could have used for water
this whole time oh that's wild very out
of character for you to miss something
like that man I yeah I assumed that you
would definitely have caught that if you
had something in your inventory problem
well he probably just overlooked it when
he opened his inventory to look for
water probably yeah
um I didn't open my inventory to look oh
my God I beat both of them what the hell
no one of them was already emptied not
refilled what the hell man some of us
don't refill Apparently after we're done
the one on the left was refilled because
I literally just filled it that's all I
am too so the right one must have been
the empty one
guys guys let's uh there's no need to
quarrel
are you the one in charge of food Mark
no no no no that's someone else are you
sure about that oh yeah yeah someone
else
mysterious fourth person who has been
hiding away on our boat
I feel very mysterious very scary I
wouldn't go near him
it's very well I also let all this time
you were responsible for that no no very
well very true actually uh if you don't
think about it I feel like suddenly we
really don't have any food yeah it's a
strange conundrum this fourth person
really is a menace
I should hunt him down
don't come back for me if I die hey guys
the shark is eating us oh never mind
I know the shark ate us I'm gonna make
you guys something delicious and we have
a whole bunch of fish that we're
seriously not eating for whatever reason
hey some of the smaller ones we were
saving for Mark to use in his big
recipes remember why don't you take one
of these
you like them
wait no one one did you take two
what should take two
no
food
okay
here you go Wade
is that a
Fair Wade for you because I love you oh
thank you okay bye
well you threw it in the water so it was
on the boat for me oh for me it was
sinking down the ocean oh for me it
landed right in your hand I literally
placed it into your mouth on my screen
yeah well if you watched my footage like
here Wade and you threw the ball into
the ocean that's nuts all right I'll
hunt down this mysterious you heard me
you I didn't hear you
all that hurt me not one of your better
speakers your speakers know nothing of
mine so you you take you take
you take you take you beat you big you
take big taker you take you think you're
gonna break soon it's almost like you
should make yourself a machete before
you go back into the world where we need
a lot of machetes they're very resource
heavy though oh no I'm drowning I'll
find this one
I have one more bowl of soup Wade would
you like one Wade
it was delicious did you drink
[Laughter]
how long does it take
oh it's done
all you have to do is complain that's
why that's how you speed it up
interesting about that go back to the
city
oh
oh oh
we already gets
ah Maybe
what are we doing I can't hear you
you want some soup
oh I hate you I mean wow I'm not gonna
give you some soup now you didn't you
drank it in front of me and threw the
empty bowl at my feet yeah but you don't
know that he was gonna do that again
yeah anybody want soup
uh yeah welcome all right I'll bring you
some oh sorry I left I had a bunch of
soup I could have given you as much as
you want Wade
oh I'm gone now though so I'll have soup
with me don't worry
okay I will completely avoid my location
at all
wait I'm suspicious of Mark's uh
implications I will have soup what do we
have to do but I'm desperate at this
point because uh well you left me with
no soup there's nothing to suspiciate oh
yeah no I have a ton of soup sorry I
could absolutely have shared some with
you yeah well you could still be around
if we were right I'm like so far away
right now I just need to get into the oh
wait this is the building that you were
in Wade hey wait I'm in the building
you're in are you still here uh no oh
because I have soup for you oh that's
great I found titanium is that important
yeah probably yeah
no no no no no
no no no
we can soup this out come on now yeah
what's up you like Superman I don't know
yeah yeah man how much soup you need I
got all I got so much more soup than
Mark either yes I have I have all the
soup and he doesn't have any ideas yeah
yeah but except not that uh Wade where
are you at home
whoever's leaving the tower buy all the
cars oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh that's
uh that's not me careful careful careful
you're dealing with the devil here yeah
yeah
oh
you can't see me now there's a tree
block
now you would be able to see me ah uh
Elixir and zoom wherever he is and give
him a big old kiss I'm very high up in
the sky on a building looking down ah
there it is I noticed from elixion's
Ruby Red Lipstick all right jump down
and face first into the Super Bowl oh
are you gonna do like a like a like a
circus act like a trick yeah do a dive
hey
stuff great moves
hey what's up with that dude oh well
let's kill this guy first
all right so you got the titanium right
you got here you got 13. for the soup
first silly super first
he's lying at you
he's a lying light on the ground all
right I'll throw some soup on the ground
don't you drink it don't don't let him
that's it
there's no soup in there all right all
right here's the soup
damn it no I got an extra in here here
all right there you go there's your soup
thank you